welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
that was meant to be giving himself the
week off
then two big batman updates came out
back to back
and yeah we just have to talk about them
now throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the new leaks about the
joker
how it's going to set up the clown
prince of crime as the villain of the
trilogy
and some other bits of amazing info this
video is going to cover the bat cave as
well
wayne manor and a lot more so i
definitely think it's news that's gonna
put a smile on your face
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the movie potentially
ruined then i highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel to never miss an update on
the film
and please drop a thumbs up if you're as
hyped as we are without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our batman leaks breakdown
okay so it's pretty much a given that at
some point
batman would end up going toe to toe
with the joker the clown prince of crime
is the arch nemesis of the dark
detective
and if you're planning on making a
trilogy with the character you just
you just have to have the two go head to
head naturally fans have been wondering
how the upcoming matt reeves movie will
be setting up things
and today we got a brand new report from
website the direct
that said the following according to our
contributing insider
daniel rickman matt reeves is planning
to introduce a new joker into his batman
trilogy
reeves is planning for the joker to
appear in the second and third movies as
one of the film's multiple villains
this new joker will be referenced in the
2021s the batman
and casting for the role has not yet
begun so
some pretty good news but since the
story broke
i actually had a big batman account
discuss some of what they'd heard about
the appearance
now take this with a pinch of salt but
apparently there's already been a
stand-in for the joker that will appear
in a scene in arkham asylum
and there will be a reference at the
time that the two fought with one
another
matt reeves is planning on having
multiple villains in his movies
so he's clearly focused on world
building we also know that this is a
year 2 storyline
so it does make sense to actually have
the character already having clashed
with the dark knight
if you've been keeping up to date with
our other batman league videos then
you'll know that it looks like the
batman is going to be heavily based upon
the earth 1 graphic novel by jeff johns
however i must say the joker doesn't
actually feature in that
so it could be a completely different
take who knows
we might even find out how that joker
got those
wonderful tattoo i mean scars now i
would absolutely
love to see joker appearing throughout
an entire trilogy
and that really feels like something
that nolan was trying to set up
batman begins of course ended with a
tease of the joker card
and then the dark knight allowed heath
ledger to come out in full force
unfortunately the actor sadly passed
away before the movie's release
and thus he was never able to feature in
the third film it was a massive tragedy
that definitely makes bat fans feel like
they were robbed slightly
and i think it would be amazing if we
actually got to see the two battling
over three movies
who knows nolan may have even given
reeves some of his ideas for the third
film
that ultimately were not used now with
these rumors as it's currently just to
stand in
that does mean that they are likely
getting a new actor for the role
i would of course love the phoenix to
rise from the ashes and go head-to-head
with pattinson
as he gave one of my favorite portrayals
of the joker ever
and with a couple of awards under his
belt
it's not too bad to have him attached to
your movie however
so far we've had no confirmation of him
appearing outside of his solo movie
so naturally we're gonna speculate over
who else could fit in the role
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on who should be playing the joker so
drop them below
but the best one i've seen is someone
saying that robert pattinson
could play them both it's obviously a
stupid idea
but also an amazing one at the same time
another great suggestion is willem dafoe
and it's very obvious as dafoe just
looks the part
but after the pair were together for the
lighthouse it just
it just makes me want to see them back
in each other's arms
dancing and marry jig now as for the
scene
i actually trust this source quite a lot
and they have
asked not to be mentioned but hey it's
your boy definition
you know we scrutinize people you know
i'm the ponderizer
and i do think that this is coming from
a place of legitimacy
and when you look at all the rumors
going around at the moment that the
joker is in the movie but no one is
actually playing him
then this leak of a stand-in definitely
lines up
still low freeze your expectations until
we get
more information but at least things are
looking very likely that joker will
appear in the film
in some form or another either he's
gonna be an arkham inmate
or a lovable comedian that tells jokes
about how
his son was killed in a drunk driving
accident
yay anyway shooting is just about to
restart on the movie
and thus this is dropped at a time when
i think that the rumors would start to
circulate once more
in addition to this i've also had a
couple of new ones that have been sent
to me that are definitely worth talking
about
you know we like to tease you here at
the channel though so before we get into
that
i just wanna let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the marvel
phase three part two box set to one
random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the leaks in the comment
section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of june and the set
will be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
okay so right after i dropped my last
video i got sent a message from the same
person that dropped the joker info
and like i said i do trust this a lot it
gives more information on the way that
wayne manor and the batcave will operate
and confirms some of our suspicions
about the way things are going
the message says i'd say out of
everything i've heard about the film
the bat cave and wayne manor are
definitely the most interesting part
wayne manor is inspired from rockefeller
manor and
is in the heart of gotham city the bat
cave is in an industrial garage with
several of his gadgets in different
stages of development
the production design is extremely
unique very 70s inspired and gothic
not sure how batman moves in and out of
wayne manor without being seen
i assume that he uses underground
tunnels to travel gotham city
all this info is from the guy who leaked
the no more lies images
now this is why i trust this source as
they've been in contact with the person
that leaked the big no more lies image
and yet this info just sounds crazy
it's hot enough to melt even the coldest
of hearts
some would say but not here because that
that jokes
too it's even bad for me that one i'm
ashamed of that
now as soon as they said industrial
garage my mind started racing
and i actually think that we may have
already seen the bat cave and just not
known it
what if right what if the batmobile
images were actually showing us the
inside of the bat cave
and we were just so fixated on the car
that we completely missed it
they clearly had the vehicle there for a
reason and to be showing us that
alongside it
just makes sense in terms of the
environment that batman would be using
in the original batman year one script
that was eventually shelled in favor of
batman begins
batman was going to be operating out of
a garage and this could be a carryover
from that
as for wayne manor just the look of
rockefeller mansion is absolutely
incredible
i looked up the house and it just
screams
wayne manner to me in order to make this
leak up that
it's going to be based on this house
someone would already have to be aware
of the mansion before they sent me this
message
and it's not actually a house that i'd
seen before searching for it
i don't know if it's big in america but
out here in england
we all live in palaces you'll see so
there wasn't much to make a fuss about
young renfreed
but yeah it looks like the perfect place
for a billionaire and it definitely fits
the imagery of what i imagine when i
think of the house that bruce wayne
calls home
now the message says that we don't know
how wayne will get in and out of the
mansion
but this might be through tunnels if you
cast your mind back to one of the
filming locations in liverpool
then you may remember it was a tunnel
itself and we actually theorized that
this was going to be a way that batman
slips in and out of gotham are noticed
without the police having any idea of
where he is if these tunnels were
present all over the entire city
and he could do it with these and it
would add even more to the characters
famous disappearing trick
there is definitely a lot going on and
though i'm still not
100 sold on these leaks just yet
you know that they definitely add some
interesting elements that
makes it sound like it's just gonna be
an incredible film
now i will of course keep you fully
updated on the story as we get more news
on it but
yeah thanks for sticking with me it's
been a very long day for me now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the leaks and who you would love to
see as the joker
comment below and let us know and if you
missed out on our other video that we
dropped today then definitely check it
out after this
we went over why batman has a nine
millimeter ammo pouch in his suit
and also some more plot leaks that talk
about the graphic novels that tie in
with the movie
there's a lot to get excited about and
it's been just an amazing day as a bat
fan
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date so hopefully we see over there very
soon
you said see that new end screen there
actually did that as well so i've done
snow ps4 breakdown
batman breakdown new end screen another
batman breakdown
i feel like crying the wife she's gonna
leave me because
keep sitting up talking about batman
until 5 00 a.m in the morning
but thanks for thanks for appreciating
it and then i know you'll give me a
thumbs up so i love you